[Musique]
nous allons mieux un progrès pré-
écologie pour l'isolement du virus est une
souche,
c'est un signe clair que l'
épidémie de souche la plus sage dans la chaîne de peinture est
différente de ce qu'elle était il y a deux mois,
elle a clairement indiqué la souche virale,
c'est une épidémie majeure  souche dans les
pays européens, donc c'est de l'extérieur
de la Chine amené à Pékin pourrait-il être
possible de n'importe quel pays européen ou
peut-être des États-Unis ou de la
Russie, donc le brin européen est très
répandu dans de nombreux
pays différents, ce n'est pas en Chine oh  vous
savez derrière le virus a été détecté maintenant
cette fois, les nouvelles infections à Pékin
sont également liées à un marché alimentaire qui est
une question très intéressante et aussi une
question très très importante à laquelle répondre,
donc nous ne comprenons pas encore cet
environnement, en particulier l'environnement de poids de code
peut  capable de maintenir la
survie des survivants pendant longtemps et on nous
propose encore différentes
hypothèses scientifiques essayer de répondre à cette question
obtenir cela  la réponse est très importante, elle
comprend comment cela devient épidémique comment
cela commence cela peut également nous aider à
comprendre ce qui s'est passé dans le whoo-hah il y
a quelques mois c'est possible mais cela
ne le précise pas définitivement à
partir de fruits de mer importés cela pourrait
être  toute personne infectée porte le
virus lorsque le marché du sélecteur et se fait
contaminer tout transmetteur
des personnes infectées aux personnes travaillant sur le
marché
vous